ADAM ALTER: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for having me.
I'm very, very happy
to be here today.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to talk a little bit
about the book and some
of the research that I
discuss in the book.
I'm going to sample a little
bit from each of the three
sections in the book.
And then I'm going to leave
plenty of time for questions.
So if you have any questions,
you can store them up.
If they're burning questions and
you have to get them out,
and you think that they will
clarify what I'm saying, I'm
also happy to take questions
earlier on before
the end of the talk.
So I'm pretty flexible
from teaching.
I'll take them whenever
they come.
So the title of the book is
obviously a bit opaque if you
don't know what drunk
tank pink is.
So I'm going to explain what the
title means in a minute.
But I want to start first by
talking about the subtitle,
the bit after the "Drunk Tank
Pink." It's "Unexpected Forces
that Shape How We Think,
Feel, and Behave."
So, the basic idea here is
that there are lots of
metaphors for the human mind.
I'm just going to use this
one for the moment.
And, the way we often think
about the mind is there's a
small part of it, just as with
an iceberg, that it is above
the surface of conscious
awareness.
And we have pretty good access
to that part of it.
When someone asks you a question
and you respond, that
response obviously is
a direct reply to
whatever they asked you.
That is all above the surface
of conscious awareness.
But there's a ton of stuff going
on below the surface.
And this book is about that
stuff below the surface.
So I'm interested in focusing
on that huge chunk of the
iceberg below the surface of
conscious awareness, the stuff
that we don't have access to
via direct introspection.
And that's what this
book is about.
So what I've tried to do in the
book is I try to say here
is this edifice of iceberg.
How can we populate it
with information?
What is actually making our
minds what they are and
forming our decisions and our
thoughts and our actions?
And how can we say this little
chunk of the iceberg, what's
causing that?
It's these things.
And so I'm trying to explain
what that iceberg is.
And I go through in the book a
whole lot of different forces
that are shaping us that
make the iceberg what
it happens to be.
So just to move away from that
metaphor, I'm going to tell
you now more about the title.
Drunk tank pink is
actually a color.
And it's this very bright bubble
gum, Pepto Bismol,
amoxicillin color that reminds
people of their childhoods
when they were taking
horrible medication.
And the origin of
the color is--
it's about now 40 years old
since it was first identified.
There were two researchers
in Canada.
And they were very curious about
how they could improve
behavior in classrooms,
reduce truancy rates.
And so what they did
was they went to
classrooms all around Canada.
And they started to paint those
classrooms different colors.
And it was an exercise
in exploration.
They weren't really sure which
colors would be most effective
and which ones would perhaps
be less effective.
They had lay theories about
which ones would work and
which ones wouldn't.
And so they painted different
classrooms different colors.
And they measured the effects
on the students.
Were they better behaved?
Were they smarter?
Did they seem to give better
contributions?
It was reasonably
unscientific.
It wasn't done with a very,
very careful hand.
But I think it was a useful
enterprise because it started
a new movement.
And what they found was that
blue is pretty good sometimes.
It pacified people a little.
It reminded the kids of
the sky and the ocean.
Green reminded them of nature.
Yellow made them a little
bit more vibrant.
It's hard to know exactly
whether all that stuff is
true, whether the researchers
expected to
see that in the students.
But one thing they found that
they were pretty certain of
was that this color pink
lulled the students and
pacified them.
And they were much
better behaved.
They were more quiet, a little
bit more thoughtful.
And so they became more curious
about this color pink.
And instead of investigating all
the colors further, they
thought, let's try to do a
more careful scientific
exploration of what this color
pink does to people.
And so in one of the
experiments, a researcher,
Alex Schauss, wanted to see
whether he could make strong,
adult males weaker, pacify them
with this color pink,
simply by using a color.
So what we did was he ran an
experiment with this tool,
which is called a handgrip
dynamometer.
It sounds like a tool
of Scientology.
But it's simply a device that
measures how hard you grip
with your hand.
And so what he did was
he had a group of 153
healthy male subjects.
They walked into the room.
And he held up the piece of
cardboard in front of them.
And half of them saw the blue
cardboard first, half saw the
pink cardboard first.
But what he did was he said to
them, I want you to stare at
this cardboard for a minute.
And they stood staring
at the cardboard.
And then he said, I want you
to grip this dynamometer as
hard as you can.
And he measured how much force
they could exert with their
hands after staring at
the pink cardboard.
And then after doing that they
did it again, this time with
the blue cardboard.
And you can see why he needed
to counterbalance which one
they saw first because you're
obviously generally weaker
after doing it once.
And the results were
pretty striking.
So what he found was that of
the 153, 151 of them, or
98.7%, were stronger after
looking at the blue cardboard
rather than the pink cardboard,
which is a pretty
striking result.
All they're doing is staring
at a piece of cardboard.
And we're constantly exposed
to a world of color.
And this suggests that with
the right color, you can
engineer behavior, or at least
tweak behavior in certain
directions.
And so this was a
striking effect.
And he took this effect
on the road.
And he started to
talk about it.
It gained currency.
He was on American talk shows.
And one of the things he found
was that people in the prison
industry-- not industry--
the prison guards were very
interested in this effect.
So one of the things they were
very curious about was how
they could pacify
the prisoners.
And so he came across two people
who were working at a
naval prison in Seattle named
Baker and Miller, and that's
where the color's other name,
Baker-Miller Pink, comes from.
And what they did was they
painted the inside of one of
their drunk tanks, which is
where the name comes from,
this bright pink color.
And they reported that over
the following nine months,
there was not a single person
who emerged from that chamber
still aggressive, even though
when they threw them in there,
they were aggressive.
And so putting them in this
drunk tank pink colored cell
for 15 minutes, they argued,
completely pacified them.
And it also gained currency
in other arenas.
So one other thing that happened
was coaches at a
number of football teams at a
number of colleges decided
that they would paint
the visiting
locker rooms this color.
And so you can obviously
understand
what they were thinking.
The reasoning was that by
painting the visiting locker
rooms this color, you would
pacify your opponents.
And at halftime, they
would sit in there.
They would have gone in ready
for the next half.
They will come out, obviously,
a lot weaker.
And that's how the
theory went.
The NCAA wasn't impressed.
And they mandated for a little
while that you had to paint
both locker rooms
the same color.
And so they had to paint
these white.
But, it turns out that the
University of Iowa still has
one locker room that's
painted this color.
You can see it's not
just the paint.
It's the color of everything--
the lockers, the
urinals, the carpets.
So this is the origin
of drunk tank pink.
And it's the opening anecdote
that I discuss in the book.
And the whole book is
about these cues.
So color is just one of the
nine cues that I talk
about in the book.
I'm going to touch on a few
others here today just to give
you a sense of what populates
the book and what I think
populates that range of forces
that shape how we think, feel,
and behave.
I'm going to talk about them
in three different ways.
The first is the stuff that just
resides inside our heads,
the information in our
heads that shapes us.
I call this the world
inside us.
The next thing I'm going to
talk about is the world
between us.
So, the fact that we're a social
species is actually
very important for all
sorts of behaviors.
And I'm going to talk about how
the interactions we have
with other people influence
our behaviors.
And then at the end, this is
where color would come in.
I'm going to talk about the
physical world, or the
world around us.
You can see these cues get
broader and broader and
broader as we go out from
the narrow ones, the
world inside us.
So starting with the world
inside us, I'll talk a little
bit about the effect of names.
And, in the world of cognitive
psychology and social
psychology, some experiments
have been done to look at how
we feel about different letters
of the alphabet.
And it turns out that if I ask
all of you to look at this
array of letters, just think
about whether you have some
favorite letters there.
It's not a question you're
asked very often.
There's not a lot of content in
letters for you to latch on
to so that you feel that you
like one more than the other.
Maybe you like one shape
more than the other.
But one fairly robust piece of
evidence suggests that we are
50% more likely to circle the
letters that are associated
with our names, especially
the first letter.
So me, as Adam Alter, I'm very
likely to circle A. And I do
feel a strange kinship
with the letter A.
And this is true across a whole
lot of the different
countries and languages
and alphabets.
It doesn't just have to be done
with the English alphabet
or the English language.
And it's been shown pretty
robustly across a whole lot of
different alphabets
and groups.
But of course, we do more
than just name people.
We also name things
like hurricanes.
So if you look at these two
images here, these are
Hurricane Katrina and Rita from
the very devastating 2005
Atlantic hurricane season.
And the way we identify
hurricanes as a matter of
convenience is we go down the
alphabet and we pick different
names for them.
And what we used to do before
this, before the 1950s when
the Weather Service got
involved, we used to just say
this is hurricane latitude
this, longitude that.
And it was very hard to
keep track of them.
And so we now use these names
as a matter of convenience.
And, one of the questions in
this book that I ask is, does
it matter what we name
these hurricanes?
Based on the fact that we know
that people are attracted to
their initials, does
that matter?
So another way of putting this
is, if you had two hurricane
relief teams that you were
putting together made up of
celebrities, would it matter
whether the green group was
the team that was trying to
raise funds after Katrina or
after Rita?
Or whether you chose the blue
group to raise for one or the
other, should that matter?
And if you look at these
celebrities, if you think
about them, can anyone notice a
difference or something that
marks the green team as one
group and the blue team as
another group?
K versus R names, which is
especially true for Kevin
Kline and Ryan Reynolds.
So all the people in
the blue group
happened to have R names.
And all the people in the green
group have K names.
And it turns out that this
actually does matter.
So there's some pretty good
evidence that after Hurricane
Katrina, people whose names
began with K donated about 2.5
times more to that charity than
they did to any other
charities that weren't
K related.
And the same for Rita.
In fact, it was an even
stronger effect--
3.6 times more to Hurricane
Rita relief than to non-R
hurricane relief.
Now, we should be able
to use that.
That implies all sorts of
interesting things.
One thing it implies is that
we should consult the
demographic makeup, or the
name makeup in the US, to
decide how to name
our hurricanes.
We shouldn't be doing
this randomly.
So if you look at the way names
are distributed in the
population of the US now, what
you find is that some letters
are more represented
than others.
So there are many more J names
and M names and A names and R
names than there are O names
or V names or Y names.
And so that suggests that we
should perhaps be naming our
hurricanes a little
bit differently.
And I'll explain why that is.
The other thing we could do is
perhaps take some letters out
of our loop.
And instead of naming hurricanes
Oscar, Olga, and
Omar as we do every few
years-- these are from
different hurricane lists that
cycle through each year--
perhaps we should leave the
letter O out altogether.
And if you look at this year,
this is the list of hurricane
names that we'll be going
through, from Andrea to Barry
to Chantal.
You can see it's 20 different
names picked from the
different letters
of the alphabet.
And that's going to be true
for all the other years.
We have six different lists
that we cycle through.
And if you focus on this list
this year, let's try and work
out whether this is
an optimal list.
Is this how we should
be naming our
hurricanes this year?
If people identify with their
initials, perhaps they also
identify with their names.
And so the same principle
should work.
And so if we look at these names
and do the same thing,
we look at how common these
names are in the population--
I'm representing the commonness
of these names by
how large the font is.
So Karen and Melissa and Jerry
are quite common as names go.
Andrea is pretty common.
But a lot of the other names
here are completely
underrepresented.
So if people are going to
donate more to hurricane
relief charities when the
hurricane happens to share
their name or their initial,
than perhaps we're not doing
this as well as we could.
And you could optimize
this better.
So one thing you could do, I've
now changed the scale of
that slide.
This is on the same scale as
this newly rescaled slide.
These names are the best names
we could pick for each letter,
the most common names with
each letter in the US
population.
So if what we're trying to do
is maximize the number of
people who see these names and
think something, it drives
into to give a little bit more,
we could be doing much
better than the names that you
have on this current list.
We could take these names,
and we would tap into the
sentiments of many, many more
people in the American
population.
And in fact, if you look across
the last 12 or 13 years
at the 27 most damaging
hurricanes and how much relief
they attracted, what you find
is that the actual donations
were around $10 billion in
the relief aid funds.
If you remove this name-letter
effect-- this tendency for
people to be drawn to their
initials and to give more--
had that effect not operated,
people would have only given
about $9.5 billion.
So we would have had about
$500 million less in aid
donation than we actually had.
If we'd optimized this and
picked exactly the right
names, we would have attracted
an extra 7%, or $700 million.
This is a completely cost
free innovation.
It's not even an innovation.
It's just a matter of changing
the names of these hurricanes.
It costs the government
nothing.
The National Weather
Service doesn't pay
much to change names.
We know that this year the
Weather Channel has started
naming winter storms.
They've started naming
them terrifying names
like Nemo and Sandy.
And of course the storms are
devastating, but the names are
sort of picked reasonably
randomly.
And the suggestion here is that
if you really want people
to engage with these names, you
should obviously pick the
names a little more carefully.
So this is just one effect.
The question is, what should
you look for in a name when
you're picking names?
This is a slightly different
stream of research, but it's a
pretty common question.
How should I name
things myself?
The first factor that's very,
very important is the fluency
of the name.
How easily can you pronounce
the name?
There's a lot of research
that's been
done on this question.
So the test we give people to
determine how fluent a name is
we ask them, imagine that
you're at the Oscars.
You've opened the envelope,
and you're about to
pronounce this name.
How easy or difficult
is that for you?
Another way of thinking about
it is that this is known as
the 191 variants of
Catherine test.
So it turns out there
are a lot of
variations in the name Catherine.
These are some of them.
And some of them are easier
to pronounce than others.
So we have, for example,
Katrina is
pretty easy to pronounce.
This is also pronounced Katrina,
but it's not as easy
to pronounce based on
what you're reading.
This is also Katrina.
Very, very difficult
to pronounce.
And so these are different ways
of writing the same name.
And the argument here is you
could just pick the simplest
name, and that would be the
best name to go with.
And this actually does matter
in the real world.
This stuff does matter.
And I've run some analyses
looking at law firm
partnership.
How long does it take people to
rise up the ranks in a law
firm to become partner?
And what I'm showing you here
is how long it's been since
these people graduated
from law school.
And obviously, one of the big
things people want to achieve
is partnership as quickly as
possible for obvious reasons.
If we separate all the lawyers
in my sample, a number of
thousands of lawyers, into those
who had disfluent names
determined by the Oscar test
and those that had fluent
names determined by the same
test, after three years, none
of them are partners yet.
None of them were prodigies
to that extent.
But after eight years, you
find there's a gap.
The fluently named lawyers have
become partners slightly
more quickly.
After 12 years, that
gap persists.
But after 16 years the gap is
closed, which suggests that
there's no difference
in ultimate ability.
It's not like the disfluently
named lawyers will never
become partner.
But they become partner much
more quickly when they have
fluent names.
And so that's what
this suggests.
We control for a whole
lot of factors.
One of the questions people
have is, maybe it's about
out-groups and foreignness and
ethnicity and stuff like that?
And you can control for that.
So if you get the pictures of
all of these lawyers from the
web, you can just pick the
people who have Anglo names,
who are white skinned,
who are male.
So take the absolute in-group,
and you find that the effect
persists even when you just
look at those groups.
And so these names have serious
implications for
various real-world behaviors.
Here's another one.
We looked at some financial
stock performance data.
So on this vertical axis here,
you have the expected change
in price based on the modeling
that we did after just one
day, when the stock has been
trading for only one day.
And on the x-axis, on the
horizontal, you've got how
easy it is to read the company's
name, from very,
very easy to very difficult.
I'll give you some examples
of those in a second.
But this is what you can expect
from the data, that if
you name your stock with a very
easy name, you can expect
a bump on average of 14%
after just one day.
If you name it with a very hard
name, you can expect the
price of the stock to
decline by 15%.
And you can see this
continuum.
It's a pretty powerful
effect, just by
choosing a different name.
And we control for as many
different things as we can to
isolate this fluency
construct.
And the effect, as you can
see, is pretty powerful.
And here are two examples.
Capital American, that was
one of the easiest
to pronounce names.
That rose by 17%.
And this Hungarian
telecommunications company--
I'm not going to try
and pronounce it--
is bust.
It doesn't exist anymore.
It didn't really take in
the American market.
Of course, there are home
biases as well.
We know when we invest in stocks
that we have a strong
preference for the
home stocks.
We prefer those to the
foreign stocks.
So that's operating as well.
But even if you take out the
Hungarian telecommunications
company and you just focus on
American stocks, you find the
same effect for domestic
stocks.
So this fluency construct
really matters.
And it makes people feel better
about these stocks.
We could talk more about the
mechanism if you have
questions about it, why this
happens, what is the
psychology behind it.
But people feel better
about these stocks.
They perceive greater value.
And I could talk
more about that
afterwards, if you're curious.
Another thing to look
for in names is the
symbolism in the names.
So, this is from a classic
study run in the 1930s.
If I said to you one of these
shapes is a maluma, which one
do you think is a maluma?
Just call out left or right.
OK.
So almost everyone or everyone
agrees that maluma is the
curvy shape on the left.
Takete you probably think of
as the shape on the right.
Bouba is the shape
on the left.
Kiki is the shape
on the right.
We have a match in our minds
between the sound that a
particular word makes and
how that should look.
If I ask you to do it the other
way around, and I said
draw a bouba for me or a kiki
or takete or a maluma, you
will draw shapes that
are like this.
I have a friend who named his
child, her middle name is
Maluma because he wanted people
to see her as warm and
round and sweet and feminine.
So people actually do
use these effects.
And these also have major
implications as well.
This is something else in
addition to fluency you should
look for in a name.
So, Takete is seen as a more
masculine name then Maluma.
And there's a hypothesis known
as the Portia hypothesis which
suggests that--
Portia was a lawyer in "The
Merchant of Venice" who had to
dress up as a man so that she
could appear before the court.
And it's very sad that
these effects exist.
But, some researchers looked at
the rise of lawyers to the
position of judge in
South Carolina.
And they looked at every name
of all the female judges and
all the people who hadn't
become judge, as well.
And they wanted to look at
whether there was an
overrepresentation of female
judges with masculine names.
And it turns out there is.
So you can classify every single
name according to how
masculine or feminine it is.
So if 99% of people with that
name happen to be male, that's
a very male name, obviously.
And so you have names like Tom
where that's the case and
Jennifer where that's
the case.
But then you have some names--
Leslie, Kim--
where you have, obviously,
people who have that name,
some of them are male and
some of them are female.
And the Portia hypothesis
suggests that people take this
very seriously when they make
judgments, that even the name
you choose, the masculinity or
femininity of that name, can
shape how quickly or whether
you become a judge in the
legal system.
So there are many more female
judges with male names, or a
disproportionate
number of them.
This is also true
commercially.
If you look at a lot of
companies-- and actually
Google falls under
this banner.
I'll explain why in a second.
The ka sound, the hard ka, from
Kellogg's and Coca-Cola
and Cat and Costco, and the same
explosive sound, the ga
sound in Google--
this applies to that sound as
well-- those hard sounds also
have the same sort of
masculinity as takete, or the
strength associated
with those names.
And what you find is that if
you look at the top 200
companies--
this is an analysis done quite
a while ago-- but if you look
at the top companies, these are
the companies out of the
top 200 that have--
so I think it's about 38 of them
have that hard K sound at
the beginning of their names and
a lot more have that sound
in their names.
And if you look at all the words
in general, or names in
general in the English language,
only 7% of all names
and 4% all words begin
with that sound.
So there's an overrepresentation
of these ka
words or ka names in, well,
high-performing companies.
In fact, Eastman, when he
created the company Kodak,
decided to name it Kodak.
The apocryphal tale is that he
named it Kodak because the
sound was mimicking the sound
of the shutter, that he
thought it went "kodak" when
you snapped the shutter.
It turns out he actually just
really liked this hard
beginning and hard end.
He thought that Kodak sounded
powerful and dominant.
And he picked for that very
reason that name.
So that's just a sampling
from the first section.
I'm going to zip through the
second section very quickly
now and talk a little bit about
stuff that doesn't just
reside in our heads
but also how we
interact with other people.
And that's the world
between us.
I'm just going to give you
one quick example here.
This is Vladislav Tkachiev.
He's a chess grandmaster.
He's also one of the world
champions at blitz chess,
60-second games of chess.
And his 2009 world
rank was 58.
He's a very impressive
chess player.
But he also is known, and
better known, because
sometimes he turns up to matches
drunk and has fallen
asleep on occasion
during matches.
And also, he's known as the
playboy of chess because he
created the World Chess
Beauty Contest.
And he decided that all female
chess players who are
grandmasters should submit
photos of themselves into a
beauty contest.
And one question some
researchers had on the back of
this is, does this
actually matter?
I mean, it's offensive,
obviously, but does it matter?
Does it matter if you
are an attractive
female playing chess?
Does that change how people
play against you?
This is Carmen Kass.
She was the model for Christian
Dior's J'Adore perfume.
She also happens to
be one of the best
chess players in Estonia.
And she was the head of the
Estonian Chess Federation.
So the question is, when you're
playing Carmen Kass, if
you're a hot-blooded
heterosexual male, does it
matter that you're playing
Carmen Kass rather than
someone else who's making
the same moves,
the identical moves?
Now, these people
playing against
Carmen Kass are experts.
They are very, very good
chess players.
They don't make moves
randomly.
They've thought a lot about
the moves they're making.
And they've probably
come across similar
games in the past.
They're very advanced players.
And they also should
be hyper-rational.
They should be about as rational
as humans are.
But some researchers looked at
how people react when they
play against these players who
are more or less attractive.
These are not images
that I created.
This is from the website
Hot or Not.
And you can take an average of
all the faces that get low
ratings and high ratings.
And that's what you get.
The question is, would it matter
playing chess against
these different people?
And the research shows that if
you look at all the games
among grandmasters from '97 to
2007, this effect applies to
heterosexual males who are
playing against women.
You find that when they play
against the slightly less
attractive players, you get many
more conservative draws.
They play a more conservative
game.
They're a little bit
more careful about
what they're doing.
Their moves are not quite
as risky or extravagant.
But when they play against an
attractive woman, they make
many more risky moves, both
their opening moves, their
opening gambit, they tend to
select a much more risky one--
almost as though in evolutionary
terms they're
trying to impress the woman
who's in front of them with
their daring.
But then they end up losing
many more games.
You also find that the moves--
so not just the opening
gambits but also the moves
throughout the game and the
outcomes of the games-- they
tend to win in a spectacular
fashion or to lose, to bomb,
in a spectacular fashion.
And people have commented that
it's striking to watch my
friend play this game.
He's never played a game
like that before.
And often, that happens when
he's playing against a very
attractive female.
And there's a lot of research
showing the same thing, that
we are swayed by the people
around us in all sorts of
unexpected ways.
So even the most rational of
us can be swayed by the
people around us.
So that's focusing a little bit
on the world between us.
There's a lot more to that.
But I want to quickly jump over
to the world around us.
This is where color comes in.
I'm going to look at a different
cue, though, instead
of looking at color.
And that's the power of nature
to be a barrier between us and
some stressor.
So there's some fascinating
research that was conducted at
Paoli Memorial Hospital in
Lancaster in Pennsylvania.
And this was a group of people
who were recovering from
gallbladder surgery in the
late '70s and early '80s.
And there were 24 of
them in each group.
And they were basically
very similar people.
There wasn't much to
distinguish them.
They were similar in terms of
their smoking history, their
exercise history,
their weight.
Other health indicators
were very similar.
So for example, if you take
patient 24 from each group,
they were matched.
Each one was yoked to
someone similar.
So we have a male who's about
24 or 25, smokes a similar
number of cigarettes,
doesn't exercise.
And each of these you
could match up.
So going into this procedure,
there's no difference.
This is a map of the hospital
from above.
And what you have here
is the rooms.
And the rooms look out onto this
area in a courtyard in
the hospital.
So these are the rooms where
people recover from
gallbladder surgery.
And they're randomly assigned
to different rooms.
They get the same treatment
from the same doctors, the
same nurses.
There is no real difference
except where they
happen to be located.
What's kind of interesting,
though, is some of these rooms
happen to look out directly onto
a stand of trees, whereas
the other ones look out
onto a brick wall.
And you can see how
that would be.
So group one, these look
out onto a brick wall.
And group two, these look out
onto a stand of trees.
It's the only difference
between these rooms.
Everything else is the same,
except the view.
So this is effectively what they
see out their windows.
And the researchers wanted to
know-- and this is a paper
published in the journal
"Science"--
does the presence of nature
through the window, the image
of nature, change how these
people recover?
And it does.
It has remarkable effects.
And I'm just going to focus on
a couple of the dimensions.
If you look at the recovery
period days two to five,
that's typically where people
are struggling the most,
because the anesthetic has
completely worn off, and they
haven't yet fully recovered.
You find the people in group
one who were looking at the
brick wall needed about six and
a half doses of very heavy
pain medication.
People in group two needed
only three doses.
No difference going in.
The only difference
is the view.
The same is also true
about how long
they stay in hospital.
So it does take some
time to recover.
But by the time you get to day
six, you find that a gap
starts to open up.
The people who were looking
at nature seem to
recover more quickly.
And that continues on throughout
days six, seven,
eight, and so on.
By day eight, half of the
patients who are looking at
this view, this beautiful view,
have-- well, it's not
even a beautiful view, it's
just a couple of trees--
half of them have left.
They've recovered.
Whereas the group looking at the
brick wall, many of them
are convalescing in
the hospital.
And so on so that by day 10
you've still got six patients
from group one who are
in the hospital
staring at a brick wall.
If anyone wants to get out
quickly and is motivated to
leave, it's those people.
And yet the presence of nature
through the window was enough
to accelerate the recovery
of these other patients.
Now, this is a small-scale
study.
This isn't thousands
of patients.
But there have been many,
many replications.
I'll talk about just
one of them.
Actually, I won't have time to
talk about it now at length.
But there's another one looking
at what happens to
children who have difficult
childhoods, either because
they're bullied or because they
have trouble at home.
And it turns out that those
who have very difficult
childhoods and endure a lot of
stress, one barrier that makes
them capable of coping with that
stress is whether there
happens to be, incidentally,
some nature around, whether
they play sports
in green areas.
And some very careful
analyses were done.
And the researchers showed, for
example, that the ones who
lived in a home with lots of
pot plants, who happened to
live near greenery rather than
an urban concrete environment,
were much more likely
to still be OK.
They were happier about
themselves.
They had higher self-esteem.
They succeeded at school just
because there appeared to be
some natural environment
around them.
So nature is a very powerful
buffer against stress.
Another effect in locations
that I think is really
interesting is the
effect of noise.
Does anyone recognize this?
This is New York City.
It's a part of Manhattan.
It's the only place where a
large interstate freeway goes
through-- a highway goes
through Manhattan.
Does anyone recognize that?
Yeah.
It's the George Washington
Bridge where it comes into
Washington Heights.
And this is I-95, obviously
one of the busiest, most
densely packed highways
in the US.
And the question was, for people
who happen to live near
this highway, what's the
effect on these people?
And the area that I've circled
in red here, there's a series
of tall high-rise buildings.
They're all identical.
And they happen to be situated
directly on top of the
freeway, known as the Bridge
Tower Apartments.
These are the apartments
from the side.
And they're about
32 stories high.
And one thing you can do is you
can measure the sound, the
level of sound, the ambient
sound, at each of these
different levels.
So you find, for example, that
obviously there are different
levels as you go up because it
gets softer as you go higher.
At the first level, if you
happen to live on the ground
floor, the background noise is
86 decibels, which is about
what you'd expect.
You're near a freeway.
It's the sound of a
truck going by.
That's pretty serious noise.
At the eighth level, the sound
drops to 66 decibels, which is
obviously quite a lot lower.
It's a logarithmic scale.
So it's about 100 times
less sound.
I think that's right.
And it's basically like being
in the presence of a loud
vacuum cleaner.
As you go up, at level 20, it's
like being in a crowded
department store with people
humming and chatting.
And then by level 32, it's
much, much softer.
It's what you'd hope your
home would sound like.
It's only 55 decibels, which is
less than the sound of very
light chatter.
So this is a family sitting
around enjoying a fireplace.
And it turns out that there's a
very big difference between
this first floor and
the 32nd floor.
There's a huge difference in
the amount of sound that
enters the ears of the people
who live there.
One of the questions the
researchers asked was, what
does this mean for people who
live there, especially
if they have kids?
Does this matter?
And so what they did was they
approached people who lived on
these different floors, and
they asked their children
various questions.
So one of the questions they
asked was, can you
discriminate between these
different sounds?
So this child here is asked,
what is the word
that's being spoken?
And they heard the word
in their ears.
And the word was either
beer or gear.
And they were asked, which
word did you hear?
And they would do another
one, robe and rope.
And they went through
a series of these.
And these are the sounds for us
when we hear them that are
the most confusable.
And they were asked what
word was being said.
Now, most people with great
hearing can achieve this 100%
of the time.
As long as the diction is clear,
you should be able to
distinguish robe from rope.
And what they found was that was
true for people who were
very high up.
These kids did very
well on the test.
They passed with
flying colors.
The kids who happened to live
on the 20th floor, some
errors crept in.
Kids who lived on the eighth
floor, more errors crept in.
So from 100% down to 95% to
88%, which suggested their
hearing has been damaged a bit
from living in this area, on
these different levels with
different ambient noise.
What's more distressing, then,
is a lot of how we learn to
read is in making fine
distinctions between sounds.
And so what they did was they
gave them reading tests.
And if you standardize the
scores so that the kids who
lived on the top floor get a
score of 100, the kids on the
20th floor scored a 93, and
those on the bottom floor
scored an 87.
This is not about demographics,
that wealthier
people can afford to
live higher up or
anything like that.
They made sure that
that wasn't the
cause of the effect.
And so what you're seeing here
is that just by living on a
noisier floor of an apartment
block, you can influence how
well your kids learn to read and
how quickly they learn to
read, which is a striking
effect.
And what shows that this
effect is due to this
prolonged or chronic exposure
to noise is that if you look
at people who'd only lived there
for much less time, for
less than four years, the
effect goes away.
So if you look at their reading
scores, these kids at
the top floor scored 100, the
ones on the 20th floor scored
a 99, and the ones on the eighth
floor scored a 98.
It's about being there
for a long time.
So there is something
you can do about it.
If you're exposed to noise for
a shorter period, the effects
are less profound.
So in a world of tiger moms
and helicopter parenting,
these are some very simple
interventions that improve the
lives of children and allow them
to deal with stress more
effectively than they
might otherwise.
The presence of nature, the
sorts of activities they do,
they engage in.
The absence of noise, if at all
possible, which is tricky
in Manhattan.
But it does suggest that of the
constellation of features
or cues that might shape your
decision about whether to buy
one apartment or another, or
to live in one apartment or
another, maybe noise should
factor in more than it does
for a lot of us.
So maybe it's nice to
have a good view.
But also, another benefit of
being higher up is it's going
to be more quiet.
And that's also an
important factor.
So I've sampled some anecdotes
from throughout the book and
some studies from throughout
the book.
I started by talking
about names.
It's the world within us.
And I moved on to the
characteristics of other
people in chapter five.
It's the chess players.
And then I talked a little bit
about locations when I talked
about nature and the
presence of noise.
There's obviously quite
a lot of other
stuff in there as well.
Drunk tank pink comes
in at the beginning.
But I talk a lot more about the
effects of colors on all
sorts of things, like
how well Olympic
competitors seem to do.
So if you have two competitors
who are equally matched--
in the Olympics, we randomly
assign them to wear
either red or blue.
It's just the way the Olympics
approaches this question of
how to decide what people
should wear.
It turns out those who wear red
win much more often than
those who wear blue.
And that's especially true when
they're evenly matched.
It seems to tip the hand
slightly in favor of the ones
who wear red.
And there are a number
of reasons for this.
Referees see people clad in
red as more dominant.
And so when they're awarding
points, they award more points
to people who wear red.
So that's another one of
the effects I discuss.
Thank you very much.
I'm happy to take questions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What got you
interested on this path of--
I don't know what field
you would call this,
but whatever it is?
ADAM ALTER: Yeah.
So mts background is in
psychology, in social
psychology and cognitive
psychology.
And those are the fields
where you discover
a lot of this stuff.
And when I was an undergrad in
Australia, I came across some
of this research in an intro
to psych class, and I was
fascinated.
I started working with some
professors there.
I started doing similar research
when I went to grad
school in the US.
And I think there are two
reasons why I wrote the book.
One is because I find this
stuff intrinsically
fascinating.
And I think other people
tend to when I
discuss it with them.
And so I thought there
was room to
describe it more broadly.
But I also think, if you look
at the hurricane example,
there's good reason
to talk about this
stuff for policy reasons.
Why shouldn't we name our
hurricanes slightly
differently?
It costs us nothing.
And in so doing, we might
attract more hurricane aid.
It just seems like
a no brainer.
So if we can capitalize on this
stuff, there are no side
effects to renaming our
hurricanes, really.
Some of the effects are great.
And so from a policy
perspective, there's a lot we
can do that we aren't doing.
And this book talks about
some of those effects.
So I think it's interesting and
because it has practical
consequences.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In terms of no
negative effects for the
hurricane, it could be
a good thing to do.
But I would wonder what the
effect on people named Sandy
is when Hurricane Sandy gets
all this horrible press.
And then similarly, if we name
all our hurricanes with
popular names if that effect
would apply [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM ALTER: Right.
Yeah.
So the question was,
what happens with,
say, Hurricane Sandy?
Once you happen to be named
Sandy and a hurricane comes
through that--
this is true for Katrina
as well.
There are negative externalities
there, that it's
horrible to be named after
something that was a tragedy.
So one argument there is maybe
what we should do is pick a
name that's uncommon but with
a letter that's very common.
So since most of the research
focuses on the letters rather
than the names, maybe we should
pick the least common
name with the letter
that's most common.
That's one answer.
But you're right.
There are always questions like
that that we should be
juggling and throwing
into the mix.
It's not obvious that there
are no externalities.
But I think in general in a
lot of these cases, these
interventions are
so inexpensive.
Another one is in Glasgow,
Scotland, and in parts of
Japan, they've shown blue lights
on certain parts of
town that reminded people
presumably of police and of
being watched, so they behaved
much more honestly.
The same is true with
billboards.
If you put up a billboard with
eyes, a pair of human eyes,
that costs very little.
But it has the effect of
making people feel like
they're being watched.
And there's good evidence to
suggest that they are much
more likely to behave honestly
when there's a billboard with
eyes around.
The same is true
with a mirror.
If you happen to open a
cupboard-- if you have a
cupboard with all your
chocolates, and you're trying
to keep to a diet, put a mirror
up, because every time
you open it, you'll be staring
into your soul as you reach in
and try to grab the food
that you're not
supposed to be eating.
So you're right.
There are some externalities
and some negatives.
But generally speaking, I think
the positives greatly
outweigh the negatives.
Hi.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious for the
hospital example, how do you
know that it's a difference
between a beautiful and not
beautiful view?
So for instance, what if you
were looking at a skyline view
that was beautiful and
had shrubbery?
How do you know it's nature
and not just beautiful
[INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM ALTER: You're right.
Yeah.
So it could be-- the question
was, how do we know that it's
not just beauty?
How do we know that it's not
just that one view is nicer
than the other?
Like what if you had a really
ugly natural view or a really
pretty view that's sculpted,
but it's concrete?
And that's a great question.
And it's not something you can
address without study.
But a lot of other studies
ask the same question.
So in one study, people watched
the most horrific
video you can imagine
of animals being
put through an abattoir.
It's a very distressing video,
and it's a propagandist video
that tries to get people to
eat less meet, obviously.
And they watched this video.
And when they then performed
various mental tasks, they did
much worse on the task,
as you'd expect.
They were distracted and
a little bit disturbed.
And what they did with other
people was they got them to
walk through a beautiful natural
environment or a
beautiful environment or a very
nice environment that
wasn't natural.
And they found in that
experiment, even though the
beauty of the two environments
was rated equally highly, that
only the natural environment
had this positive effect.
And one of the arguments is that
one of the things that
distinguishes a natural
environment from a built
environment, even if it's
beautiful, is that a built
environment is static.
A natural environment, you
have the rustle of wind
through leaves.
You have the movement
of a river.
All of that stuff is critical.
And William James was one of
the first and greatest
philosophers and
psychologists--
not the first philosopher,
but one of the first
psychologists--
he talked about two kinds
of attention.
And one of his arguments was
that it's this kind of stuff
that visits on you that you
don't have to deal with.
You don't have to dodge cars or
remember things, that your
attention is grabbed by nature
and the movement of the wind
through the trees and
all that stuff.
That's a replenishing kind of
attention, whereas it's very
stressful to have to deal with
the movement of cars and
dodging traffic and all the
stuff that we normally
associate with stress.
So there's something about the
kind of attention that is
drawn out of you from natural
environments that has this
effect beyond just beautiful
environments that aren't natural.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just on the naming
piece, have there been any
studies that looked
at the effect on
politics relating to voters?
ADAM ALTER: Yeah.
Actually, in the same paper on
lawyers, I looked at that.
We don't have real datasets.
We haven't looked at real
datasets on that.
But we show that if you give
people names of politicians
and you ask them to rank them
and rate them and vote on
them, they like the ones
who have simpler names.
And there's one great
anecdote.
There were some politicians
with surnames Hart and
Fairchild--
there's an article on "Slate"
about this-- and they did
extremely well.
They weren't expected
to do all that well.
And they outperformed.
And they were up against someone
whose surname was
[? Pachinski. ?]
And it was hard to pronounce,
a little bit hard to spell.
And there was a whole argument
that part of the problem there
was that when people were
saying, we should vote for
[? Pachinski, ?]
they didn't even know
what to say.
They just said, we should vote
for that candidate who had
that name that I can't remember
or pronounce.
And that that stuff ends up
mattering, especially for the
transmission of the name.
So yes, there's been some
research on that as well.
AUDIENCE: On that note, are
there any studies on people
with the same name but
[INAUDIBLE] nicknames are,
whether they're interpreted
differently by others or by
themselves, this Kat versus
Kate versus Katie or
something like that?
ADAM ALTER: I don't know of
much research looking at
nicknames as a distinct factor
beyond names themselves.
It's an interesting question,
because obviously Kat has--
or Kate or Katrina--
has so many associated
nicknames.
It's a good question, which
nickname should you pick?
I think the main argument,
though, is nicknames are a
great idea when the name is
especially complex, and you
can simplify it by giving people
a nickname to use.
And you see that a lot of people
with names that are
hard to pronounce do this
naturally, anyway.
But beyond the question of
whether one nickname is
simpler than another, I don't
know about much research
that's looked specifically
at nicknames.
That's a good question though.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This more is for the
colors but works for anything.
Have they found how much of this
is evolutionary, genetic,
long-term factor versus more
social, short-term factors?
ADAM ALTER: Yeah.
It's a very good question.
The question was, how much of
this is long-term versus
evolutionary based on a very,
very long time scale?
How much of it is just
based on association?
That's a big question
for colors.
So with drunk tank pink,
we associate pink with
femininity, which we haven't
always done.
So pink was a color that we
didn't associate with one
gender or another until
maybe 150 years ago.
And the question is, would
you have found
the same effect then?
There's some evidence
either way.
There's one study, apparently,
that reports that even--
I'm color blind, and apparently
this effect even
works on color blind people.
So I can't see that pink the
way you all see that pink,
assuming you're not
color blind.
But it's supposed to have the
same effect, which suggests
something biological, at least,
beyond the level of
pure association.
So even if I think it's grey,
it's still doing the same
thing to me.
But there are other studies
that suggest that if you
expect pink to make
you stronger,
the effect goes away.
So maybe it's about
the association.
If you retrain people to have
new associations, a lot of
these effects go away.
And it's actually a good
question, because it's a
constant theme in the book
that I talk about.
Some of this stuff is
very low level.
It goes back well into the
reaches of the past of early
humans and how they interacted
with each other.
But a lot of it is really a
product of the environment we
live in today.
And a lot of it shows that the
environment we're in today is
not the one we were over time
molded for or designed for.
And so a lot of these little
errors that creep in and
biases that creep in are a
product of that mismatch
between the people we were
molded to be in one
environment and the fact that we
haven't kept up enough with
a very rapidly changing
environment.
So I suggest some ways that
we might be able to
cope better with that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there any data
whether the pacifying effect
of pink affects men
or women more?
ADAM ALTER: There are
some results.
And it's slightly stronger with
men than it is for women.
There's one study that shows
that women don't respond as
much, that in general they are
much less sensitive to the
color than men are, which may
suggest, and I guess, that to
some extent the effect
is about association.
If men think of femininity,
perhaps that then changes how
they feel when they're gripping
the hand grip,
whereas women, maybe that it
just loses that effect.
So perhaps it's to some extent
about the association there.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]